so hello everyone today we're going to
be presenting poultry farmers guide to
FSA loans we hope that in this guide
you'll learn the basics that you need to
know in order to navigate your way
through the FSA loan process so some of
the things we'd like you to take away
today are a better understanding of the
FSA financing options available to you a
better understanding of how that
financing works and what elements make
the determination that FSA some of the
factors you should consider before
borrowing for poultry farm a better
understanding of the risks in financing
a poultry farm a better understand of
the FSA eligibility process a better
relationship with your local FSA office
and overall more confidence in your
ability to successfully manage your farm
so this workshop is broken up into three
sections section one will be a personal
evaluation things that you need to ask
yourself personally before borrowing for
a poultry farm section two will cover an
introduction to FSA loan programs so
we'll just talk about eligibility in
general types of loans types of FSA
lenders things like that and then
section 3 will be the application
process where we go through applying for
a loan approval and denial of a loan
repealing alone and then restructuring
alone so the first thing you need to do
before borrowing to financial culture
operations are to set your goals and to
ask your big questions so as a family
sit down and write out your goals
discuss them make sure that everyone is
voicing their opinions prioritize your
goals
remember that overall this is a family
farm or family operation so you're the
well-being of your family is the most
important thing think about is this
business a good time good use of your
time and resources do you have the money
time knowledge to make this business
work and does this specific financing
package work for you the price of the
mortgage note your payment that you're
going to have to make the terms the
interest rate everything like
so just remember that you're responsible
for considering all these questions
before you apply for any type of
financing so as an introduction to farm
loans we have two basic types of loans
we have an operating loan and an
ownership loan now there are other types
of loans but we're just going to kind of
talk about these because these are the
primary types of loans that most farmers
need an operating loan is a short-term
loan to persist inputs necessary to
operate your farm while an ownership
loan is a longer-term loan make for the
purchase of major farming assets like
farmland poultry houses or equipment
within FSA you have two types of loans
you have a direct loan that's a loan
made by FSA to farmers where FSA is the
lender and also services the loan and
then you have a guaranteed loan now
that's a loan made by a financial
institution like a bank or something of
that nature which is backed by FSA so in
that scenario your lending institution
is the one servicing the loan typically
that'll be someone like the Farm Credit
for example whereas FSA will financially
guarantee the loan up to ninety percent
so just to understand the risk that's
very important to do so before you apply
for a loan and understanding the steps
of evaluation are good because the
process by which your loan will be
evaluated is different from what you
need to do personally so in a loan
evaluation they'll look at eligibility
do you qualify for the loan they'll look
at feasibility does your loan repayment
plan makes sense will that farm loan
cash flow and then they look at your
collateral how much collateral you have
how much you are offering your
collateral can be real estate farms
equipment things of that nature
you know but they'll look at the total
package that you're bringing in but
things that you need to ask yourself are
how well do you really know the poultry
business have you talked to any current
or former poultry farmers what will
happen if you can't make that loan
payment how consistent is your pay as a
grower and then does your contract the
contract with your into
traitor have any type of language that
you really need to be aware of because
your mortgage is a binding contract so
you want to ensure to look at the
contract from your integrator as well so
we'll talk about collateral first and
what happens is if you default
collateral we define as an asset offered
as security for the repayment of a loan
to be forfeited in the event of a
default
so typically collateral use for farm
loans include farms farming equipment
vehicles land or your personal home so
in this scenario a default is a failure
to fulfill a loan obligation especially
to repay a loan that's something known
as a monetary obligation and therefore
if you do not repay your loan you're in
monetary default now you can be in
non-monetary default and that is where
you fail to comply with a provision of
the loan that is not relate to repayment
such as paying your taxes on the loan
keeping up with farm insurance on the
property things of that nature so when
you borrow money to fund your poultry
farm you're tying the collateral that
you offer up to the financial health of
your poultry farm and your collateral is
at risk to the financial problems of
your poultry farm so for example we
talked about personal homes may be used
as collateral so you would be tying your
personal home to your poaching farm and
if you default on your poultry loan you
may be required to forfeit your personal
home so that's something very important
to consider before offering them your
personal homeless collateral okay so
it's important that you know your
contract before you borrow for it now
this is your contract with your
integrator your poultry contract and
here are some questions that you should
ask about your contract before borrowing
money against it what is the length of
your contract is it flock to flock so
for example do you have a three-year
flock to flock contract what does that
mean does that mean that you're only
going to receive you're only guaranteed
to receive birds on a flock to flock
basis meaning that they can terminate
your contract
anytime within three years or you
guaranteed to receive X number of flocks
for a year within that three years
that's all going to be contained in your
contract also what are the rights with
your company if your determine if your
contract is terminated what are the
reasons that your contract could be
terminated often there will be language
in there contracted outlines how and why
your contract may be terminated how does
your company handle housing upgrades our
disputes handled by your company those
should all be included in there
typically speaking contracts may include
language that says upgrades can be
required kind of at will by the company
so they make the determination when an
upgrade is required it's important that
you understand how you're paid do you
does your contract including guaranteed
pay are you ranked in a tournament and
then is your density your flock numbers
your target weight everything related to
your flock of birds guaranteed in your
contract does the company have the
ability to change your density or change
your target weight without notifying you
or do they have to notify you how much
time do they are they required to notify
you by questions like this and many more
gonna be found in our copy of the FSA
guide and that's gonna be in Appendix C
all right
so tournament pay in your mortgage
payment so just so that everyone
understands tournament pay is an
incentive that's used by integrators to
encourage peak performance amongst their
contract farmers and how it works is
that under this model farms would flock
being processed during the same week of
ranks amongst each other according to
integrator cost per pound and that
becomes your tournament once your
tournament is established farmers
performance are rated above or below the
average and that determines their in pay
so farmers that are underperforming the
average will have their pay reduced mean
farmers who have a higher cost to the
company will be lower ranked ranked
below the average and will have their
pay reduced while farmers that produce
cheaper than the company average will be
ranked higher and will have a bonus
added to their pay this means that your
pay can fluctuate greatly from one flock
to the next where is your cost
specifically your mortgage payment your
loan payment will remain the same
regardless of what you're being paid so
it's essential to consider that the
average pay estimate may not be
representative of what your actual pay
will be you could earn higher but you
could also earn lower so it's always
good to estimate your cash flow and be
very realistic on how you estimate your
cash flow here in this slide you'll see
that we have some company estimates
listed on the right and some farmer
estimates listed on the left so you'll
notice that the estimated cost of
building four houses is the same 966
thousand dollars
the estimated gross income is the same
roughly a hundred sixty four thousand
dollars the estimated loan payment is
the same about ninety four thousand
dollars in change whereas the estimated
farmer costs are much different the
company estimates thirty six thousand
dollars whereas farmers that we
consulted with and our current poultry
farmers estimate closer to eighty
thousand dollars so how is this
different and why is it different
well the expenses that the company lists
are listed on the left in the expenses
that our farmers have included are
listed on the right now just so that
everyone understands every cost that the
company estimates here farmers also do
include but there are additional cost
that the farmers have include that they
know they have to pay based on their own
experience and all of these figures can
be found in our guide as well you can
refer to section C for many more cash
flow estimates just to give you a better
eye
but you'll notice that we've included
the electric bill the insurance bill the
bill for cleaning out the bill for
pressed out through property taxes and
that totals down to thirty six thousand
four hundred dollars but in that there's
additional costs for example heating
fuel the cost to fill your house with
shavings especially if this is a new
poultry operation or you've had to do a
clean-out down to the bare ground
you also have equipment fuel for fueling
your generators or maybe your digesters
or something like that that you have
around the property equipment repairs
this could be to any of your equipment
necessary to run the operation like a
cake out machine or something like that
and then you also have hired labor in
there most farmers that we talk to do
have at least one hired person on hand
to help them with their operation and
that's where the difference is and so
you can you know compare and contrast
these two different cost analysis okay
so now we're going to discuss basic FSA
loan eligibility so these are the steps
to do before you've applied so before
applying you need to seek financing with
traditional lenders the FSA eligibility
process starts with exploring financing
option with traditional lenders like
Farm Credit Bank are crazy if you are
unable to secure financing at reasonable
rates and terms then you may be eligible
for an FSA loan so of course you have to
start by first applying to Farm Credit
before applying directly to FSA now to
get started with an FSA application you
need to first have your farm number so
to be considered for a loan you must
demonstrate you are authorized to
operate your farm where it is located so
you would visit your local FSA office
with a copy of your lease your rental
agreement or proof of ownership and then
they would assist you in registering and
receiving your FSA farm number there are
a couple of conditions with this for
certain FSA loans your loan officer may
require that you complete a borrower
training course within two years of
closing the loan
your loan funds must be used within the
United States and then certain loan
requirements may exceed the lending
limits of FSA in that case you the
borrower must be able to secure the
remaining financing from another source
so for example if the FSA loan limit on
a particular program is 300,000 and you
need $400,000 you would need to secure
the additional $100,000 from a separate
lender not FSA okay so here are some
different notes on FSA loans one is the
hundred and fifty percent rule so on all
direct FSA loans have a security
requirement of at least one hundred
percent of the loan amount
however FSA will require applicants to
provide collateral up to 150% of the
loan amount if it is available in this
loan this rule specifically applies to
FSA Direct Loans only so for example if
you're borrowing $300,000 to upgrade
your poultry farm you may be required to
offer an additional hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in collateral meaning
your poultry farm and other collateral
like equipment of personal home could be
required as collateral there are some
exceptions to the hundred and fifty
percent rule for example if the asset
necessary like your tractor other
equipment shadow-like other type of
breeding stock or cattle something like
that if those are necessary to secure
credit elsewhere for farming operations
they may be accepted also your personal
home your household contents your
personal vehicles they can also be
exempt from the hundred fifty percent
rule however your home must be on a
separate parcel land so if your home is
on the exact same parcel as your farm
then it may not be exempt also working
capital accounts like your bank account
and retirement accounts like your 401k
pensions those mounts will be exempt for
guaranteed loans the FSA reviews the
collateral proposed and available and
requires the lenders to secure the lawn
to the satisfaction of both FSA and the
lender
Benni would you like to speak on that a
little bit more does that mean that they
have a little more flexibility with how
much collateral is required for a
guaranteed loan the lender is the lender
is advised and able to use what they
would do to another applicant that is
not here to mean so that sometimes goes
beyond what FSA's requirements are
excellent so in that particular case as
Benny said your individual lender may
have additional flexibility so that's
just something to keep in mind as well
okay so here are some basic types of
farm loans that are available from FSA
there are other type of loans but we're
only going to discuss these three
because these are the three primary ones
that most people use again you have a
farm ownership loan like we discussed
those may only be used to buy or enlarge
a farm make a down payment on a farm
make structure improvements on a farm
like building a building or structure
something of that nature or other
brick-and-mortar projects now you have
an operating loan and that's a loan to
cover necessary expenses associated with
improving the profitability of your farm
according to the FSA description an
operating loan will help you purchase
livestock and equipment and pay for
minor real estate repairs and annual
operating expenses you also have an
emergency loan and that according to the
FSA description is a loan that will help
you if you suffered a qualifying loss
caused by a natural disaster that
damaged your farming or ranching
operation you can find more details on
these three most common types of loan in
included in the FSA guide or you're
welcome to contact your local FSA office
also there's also conservation loans
micro loans and other types of loans but
again it's best to contact your local
FSA office if you have additional
questions about those types of loans all
right so we're going to discuss
eligibility for Direct Loans so
under direct loan you have a farm
ownership loan you have an operating
loan you have a emergency one all three
of the types of loans we discussed
previously but your loan limit is
$300,000 and if we remember from earlier
this is the type of loan where FSA is
the one directly loaning you $300,000
and they're also the one that will be
servicing that $3,000 so your general
general eligibility requirements are
have the training education or
experience to effectively manage a farm
or ranch you must be a US citizen a
nonsense and national or qualified alien
you must possess the legal capacity to
obtain a loan you must not have a
conviction related to a controlled
substance
you must be unable to obtain credit
elsewhere at reasonable rates and Terms
if you remember a few slides back we
mentioned that you first need to start
by applying for financing with a non FSA
lender and then if you're unable to find
those reasonable rates and terms that's
when you would turn the FSA so that's
what that eligibility requirement means
also you must be able to demonstrate
good credit history or if you're unable
to demonstrate good credit history you
need to show that that that the
incidences were beyond were due to
circumstances beyond your control
they were infrequent or they were not
recent you must not have had a recent
foreclosure or business failure you must
be able to show that your farm is a
family farm or ranch and the majority of
the physical labor and management is
provided by you a family member or
another entity member you must not have
received debt forgiveness on another FSA
direct or guaranteed loan and you must
not be behind on any debt to the
government when the long closes with
certain exceptions if you have questions
about those exceptions please contact
your local FSA agent okay so now we're
going to discuss eligibility for
guaranteed loans so under a guaranteed
loan we have farm ownership loans we
have operating loans we have
conservation loans and the loan limit
for that is generally 1 million three
hundred
9,000 that's adjusted annually so for
example it went up from 2016 but it may
be adjusted you know down in 2018 so
that's always something to check out
with your local FSA age so the
eligibility requirements for a
guaranteed loan are that you're a US
citizen a non sis and national or
qualify datum you must possess the legal
capacity to obtain a loan you are unable
to find a lender willing to approve your
loan with reasonable terms and rates
without a guarantee you must not have
received debt forgiveness on another FSA
direct or guaranteed loan you must be
able to show that your farm is a family
farm or ranch and the majority of the
physical labor and management is
provided by you a family member or
another entity member and you must not
be behind on any debt owed to the US
government after the loan closes there's
also some additional security
requirements on FSA guaranteed loans so
in some cases if you use chattel as the
security on more than one loan for a
guaranteed loan you may be able to do so
for a guaranteed loan but you would need
to consult your individual lender if
that's an option for you so for example
you may be able to use breeding stock or
equipment across as collateral across
two different loans Benny can you think
of a situation where that may apply sir
that would apply if your
agree this you can use your channels can
be if you are getting two loans you
needed a operating loan and you needed
another loan your channel actually can
be used as collateral in both instances
okay
excellent let's see so we want you to
understand your loan terms in order to
do that you need to understand the
terminology used in loans so for example
when we say loan terms we mean the
number of payments the interest rate and
obligations stipulated by your loan
agreement your interest rate is the
proportion of a loan charge as interest
to you the borrower the interest is the
money paid regularly at a particular
rate for money lent or for delaying the
repayment of debt and this may be fixed
or floating a fixed interest rate is an
interest rate that remains the same
throughout the life of the loan whereas
a floating interest rate is an interest
rate that is subject to change over the
life of the loan and that's also known
as a variable interest rate so most of
you have probably heard of fixed
interest rates and variable interest
rates now a floating interest rate may
be initially lower than a fixed rate but
could increase over time and that could
have significant consequences for you
repaying your loan ie a much higher loan
payment in the future a longer term will
lower your monthly payment amount but
they will result in more interest being
paid over the life of the law so while
having longer terms will increase your
ability to pay on a monthly basis by
having a lower term lower payment amount
you will overall end up repaying more
for that loan because you've stretched
your terms out over a longer time it's
critically important that you discuss
these loan terms and rates with your FSA
or your loan officer to select the
option that works best for you and you
should consider how your loan terms will
affect your ability to repay your loan
as well as affect what's your monthly
loan payment will be
so loan terms and lenders which are best
for you so we I want to discuss balloon
loans and payments because a lot of
times those come into play with poultry
loans so in a balloon loan your initial
terms for the loan typically the first
four years have a relatively manageable
payment in fixed interest rate however
after the initial three period the loan
will become due in one very large
balloon payment hence the name for you
know this type of loan if you're unable
to make the balloon payment then your
lender may renew your loan for another
balloon mode which would reset your loan
terms with a new interest rate and will
include some fees however there is no
guarantee that your lender will renew
your loan after the balloon payment is
due balloon loans are riskier or a
riskier repayment option so just because
you know they have renewed your loan
once or twice before does not mean that
they will renew it a third time and
there's no obligation for them to renew
that loan there's no obligation for them
to give you the same terms as in your
previous balloon note so just keep that
in mind when you're considering whether
or not you want to take a balloon loan
out on your poultry farm now for FSA for
guaranteed loans the lenders FSA ranking
will influence their application process
so under the FSA Lindner rankings you
have three different rankings a
preferred lender is the highest FSA
ranked lender and therefore has the most
flexibility in their application process
this means they may not require you to
go through some of the initial
application stages that other lenders
would have you be required to do so so a
certified lender is the second highest
FSA ranked lender and has more
flexibility in their application process
than a standard lender but less than a
preferred them and then standard is the
basic FSA ranking and has the least Lex
ability in their application process
again your local FSA office can come
provide a complete list of lenders as
well as their FSA lender ranking so the
FSA loan application process the
application process we've broken down
into ten general steps the first one
would be to obtain a contract or letter
of intent from your integrator if you're
not going to you're not going to get a
contract from your company there's no
reason to apply for financing you then
need to consult your company for the
proposed housing layout generally your
company knows where they want houses to
be laid out on your land and they have a
very specific idea of it and they'll
tell you right away that's important for
your environmental pre-screen or
assessment so depending on where your
houses are going that's going to affect
if you need to do a pre-screen or an
assessment it's also going to affect
whether you need to do in a historic
preservation pre-screen or assessment
and then whether or not you need to do
fish and wildlife review or not now all
poultry farmers will be required to
submit a concert comprehensive nutrient
management plan otherwise known as a
waste management plan you're also going
to need to submit a plan for your
repayment ability and your farm
operating plan that's essentially your
farm business plan demonstrating how
you're going to repay the proposed
amounts that you are refunding you also
need to submit your security requirement
so that's going to be what your
collateral be worth and what collateral
you are submitting so generally speaking
that would be a property assessment
something like that and then you'll go
through the approval process that's once
all your applications have been
submitted all documentation now FSA has
your complete application and they'll
review it and we're going to go on next
to what you do if your application is
denied or change okay so first we'll
cover what to do if your loan is denied
or chained because if your loan is
approved you move forward with
construction and getting into poultry
that
is pretty straightforward now if your
loan is denied you may appeal the
decision it's important to note that
decisions may be appealed but not
regulations Benny do you want to talk
and talk speak on that sir and
distinguish what does it mean when we
say that your decision may not be
appealed or your decision may be
appealed but not the regulations what
the what the rules say is that any
adverse decision is appealed and even
the FSA said may send you a little bit
since it's not a people that is an
adverse decision and he self is appeal
but in the appeals process you have to
argue from what the rules say you can't
argue that it rules along and when we
say the rules we're specifically saying
rule from the Federal Register order
statute there are interpretations from
their own the agency of interpretation
of what the rule says what we have not
so let's discuss just an eligibility
requirement that was pretty
straightforward that may kind of sum
this up for example if you put in an in
FSA application and you were denied
because you are not a US citizen and you
are not a legal resident you're here on
a visa something of that nature
therefore you are ineligible to receive
this financing now you would not be able
to appeal that decision because the
regular the regulation states that you
are ineligible is that that that is
correct and what you run into that is
most of the time that to me is that you
would argue were trying to argue that
you didn't every decision will have a
time specification or that's going to
reply in fits just 30 days that's from a
regulation hmm and missing that
terminates your eligibility and that's
into the rules so you
that's a regulation you can't
they can't change that I'm glad you
brought that up Betty because that
segues to what we were going to talk
about next is what are the steps if you
want to appeal your decision and as
Benny Ari mentioned those will be time
bound so the first one is you may
request a reconsideration meeting
however you have to make that request
within 30 days of receiving your
decision letter now at a reconsideration
meeting they will look at the decision
again and possibly reconsider it in sits
a reconsideration meeting here you would
present information to explain why you
believe the decision was made in error
to our earlier example if for example
you know you were denied because you're
not a US citizen but you are a legal
u.s. alien well you can appeal that you
can say well I thought that I should be
eligible because I am a legal u.s. alien
and it says that I am eligible for the
loan and then the denying loan officer
would you know argue their case on why
they denied the file so you can present
information as to while something was
made in error correct and that goes back
to the 30 days also the point the
appeals man was the natural fear of
division is the agency that handles our
Appeals if they will consider the letter
will say when you receive they will they
will all allow up to seven days normally
for May and so you know but you have to
when you appeal you have to put the date
that you received it they calculate the
days from that you know for that 30 days
and that's where it becomes regulatory
so it's very important that you ensure
that you're moving on a any type of
denial appeal in a very timely manner
and that you also keep track of when
mailings were received and when mailing
or sent off or when you applied for
things so if your decision at your
reconsideration mean does not
then you have an additional 30 days to
request either mediation or to appeal
the FSA decision you may only request
mediation or appeal the decision not
both and you only have 30 days so if you
request mediation a neutral mediator
will help the two parties review the
options and agree on a solution now if
you appeal your decision that is where
you will appeal to nan the national
appeal Division as Benny mentioned and
your appeal must be postmarked no later
than 30 days following your decision
letter so that is your decision letter
from your reconsideration meeting not
your original decision letter that
appeal would be mailed off to national
appeal division at the address provided
here in cordova tennessee now more
options sorry more detailed information
will be available in the guide as well
as from your local FSA office and
important to remember here is that your
clocks
fuck-you 30-day clock stops when you
apply for the mediation but it
immediately kicks in when that mediation
concludes so you don't have an
additional 30 days after mediation it's
just the time remaining in the 30 days
from when you originally applied for
mediation next time thank you also if
you find yourself in this situation
please feel free to reach out to a
farmer aid organization or farmer
advocacy organization you can contact us
directly at Rafi our contact information
will be listed into the presentation but
there also may be other organizations in
your local region which may be better
equipped to assist you okay
so an important part of your loan is
fulfilling your loan obligations this
entire time we've been talking about
doing personal assessment before
applying and what the application
process is like but for most of you
you're going to be spending most of your
loan life in refilling sorry fulfilling
your loan obligations this means that
you have been approved for financing you
receive the loan now it's time to repay
it so depending on the type of loan
you're gonna have different
responsibilities during the life of that
loan of course you have to make sure
that you're still making your payments
on time and that you're making them in
the specified amount but failing to
fulfill a loan obligation could lead to
a defaulter either monetary or
non-monetary and that could result in
foreclosure or FSA repossessing the loan
collateral so some of the core common
borrower obligations are paying any fees
required by FSA for a lien search
executing loan documents filing or
recording financial statements credit
checks any other kind of fees
maintaining and protecting your
collateral this is an important one for
poultry farmers because your poultry
houses are your collateral a lot of
times farmers may think while for
poultry houses I'd like to close down to
three where it's more manageable and
then I will sell off the fourth one for
scrap metal if you do that if you change
or alter your collateral without prior
authorization from FSA or your lender
you could be found in non-monetary
default that also includes if your your
farm is used as collateral and there is
timber on your farm cutting the timber
without receiving prioritization could
lead to a month non-monetary default so
make sure that you review your loan
documents review your collateral
agreement and consult your loan officer
before you do anything like that another
issue that we see lots of farmers
running into paying any and all taxes on
your property or so
sometimes some guys will let the taxes
slide for a little bit and come back and
try and pay em but if you don't pay your
taxes you may be in non-monetary default
and they may be able to foreclose on
your farm as a result on another issue
is maintaining insurance company on as
specified in your FSA loan agreement so
you may be required to maintain
insurance on your farm your poultry
houses farming equipment that may be a
certain type of insurance which means
their specifications or any of their
requirements yeah that's good because
they it says you would you would insure
it at the collateral they put your
particular dangers protecting the
collateral so the requirement is that
you made any insurers that would place
the value of that crap and so a good
example of that is a maintaining
insurance on your poultry houses we have
seen poultry houses burned down before
due to electrical fires or lightning any
number of reasons and so if you don't
have insurance that will ensure that
poultry house to the collateral value
then you may be nom nom monetary default
because you're going to be under
collateralized on that long going
forward so just keep in mind it is your
responsibility to fulfill the loan
obligations it's also your
responsibility to you know maintain all
the other obligations within the loan
such as any chickens site inspection or
providing any required documentation if
your loan for example states that you
are required to provide documentation
proving your insurance but you haven't
done so you could be a non-monetary
default even if you have insurance and
that's because you did not follow
through and provide the insurance as you
were required to do so again your loan
officer or your FSA age and can answer
additional questions about this if you
have any and please feel free to ask
them also
okay so trouble repaying your loan
restructuring none of us ever want to
get to this point but we know what
happens
no one happens in farming especially in
poultry farm sometimes you're not able
to meet your financial obligations so
what do you do if you know that you
can't make your mortgage payment first
if you're having trouble meeting all of
your financial obligations that includes
everything not just your poultry loan
but your poultry loan your personal
loans your home mortgage your vehicle
loans that kind of thing
cons consult your FSA office as soon as
possible to seek counseling it's best to
do it before you have missed any
payments because you will have many more
options available to you then after you
have missed a payment and if you cannot
fulfill all of your debt obligations
then you want to go ahead and start
contacting those creditors but for farm
and personal debts so to check your
eligibility for loan restructuring or
more restructuring details you would
contact your lender if you have a direct
loan then FSA's your lender if you have
a guaranteed loan then contact the
commercial lender your farm credit your
local bank whomever is servicing your
loan you may need to request a meeting
between FSA your lender and yourself and
just keep in mind that not all of these
restructuring programs will be available
to your particular situation but types
of restructuring include consolidation
rescheduling deferment and interest rate
reduction a write down or conservation
contract also you may come contact a
farmer advocate for financial counseling
like someone here at rafi either myself
or Benny or another organization who may
be working in your state so if you are
unable to repay your loan on time you
may default if your loan is fully
collateralized then the bank or FSA will
initiate foreclosure or liquidation
proceedings from the time you receive
the first default notice you will have a
specified amount of time before
foreclosure or liquidation will start
that default notice will explicitly
state how much time you have or it will
give you a date in the future to resolve
the issues
before that date if you receive a
default notice please contact an
attorney as soon as possible to
understand your rights if you're
available securities have been
liquidated and there is still debt
remaining you may be able to seek a debt
settlement agreement a debt settlement
is a negotiating an agreement between
you and your lindo to reduce the overall
debt in exchange for a lump sum payment
so some important persons to contact as
you're working through farming as you're
looking for FSA loans or as you may find
that you are in financial distress
anything of that nature you know contact
your local FSA office for lending policy
or you know for general questions you
can find your state offices listed at
the website here fsa.usda.gov slash
state offices north carolina specific
offices may be found at the link below
if you're a farmer in need of financial
counseling please feel free to contact
Rafi our web site for contract
agriculture can be pinned here we work
most of the contract poultry farmers or
you can contact myself or mr. Benny
bunting directly Benny is our lead
farmer advocate his telephone number as
well as email account here I myself
Tyler Whitley and the contract
agriculture case manager and my contact
information and email can be found here
as well we want to take this time to
thank you for viewing our presentation
and feel free to contact us or your
local FSA office if you should have any
questions